-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy and Peabody award-winning
actress and comedian you know
from movies such as "Trainwreck"
and her show
"Inside Amy Schumer."
Her latest series,
"Life & Beth,"
is streaming now on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-Do you have any preexisting
conditions?
-I'm a woman.
-A woman, mm-hmm.
Uh, just a few more questions.
-I can just save you some time.
I've had over 30,000 drinks.
I don't really chew my food
enough.
And I took Plan B recently.
Kind of got two uses out of it.
Don't write that.
-Hmm, I just meant
like any injuries.
-Right.
-Please welcome back to the show
our good friend Amy Schumer,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Amy, how are you?!
-I mean, I'm [bleep] depressed.
-Why?
-Just, I mean,
it's not a big deal.
Just that we're losing
all of our rights.
-Yeah, I'm sorry about that.
-Yeah, but whatever.
What else is going on?
No, but I'm wearing my
"bans off our bodies" pin.
-And you were at a protest
yesterday.
-I was at a protest yesterday.
Yeah, we really need everybody
to be standing up right now.
Men, women, everybody, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You've been very good at that.
I want to give you credit.
-Sorry, I cursed,
but, God, it's such a bummer!
-It is not
a great time right now.
-It's not good.
-Can one thing that --
Well, I guess this is good.
You are one of the people,
one of the few I know,
over the last 26 months,
has not gotten COVID.
-I know!
[ Laughter ]
You had COVID.
-I did.
-Yeah, I didn't. I haven't.
-I know.
-Yeah.
-Has anybody else
not had COVID yet?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look how smug. "Yeah."
[ Laughter ]
I don't know, God has a plan.
I don't know.
He chooses the people He loves.
-That's what you think it is?
-I don't know.
I'm a little smug about it.
I haven't had it yet.
-Well, congratulations.
-Hey, He's looking out.
[ Laughter ]
So stupid.
-I know you've said
this to me in the past.
As the weather changes,
you're very excited to go out,
have drinks outside.
-Yes, I love drinking outside
when it gets nice out.
Isn't that nice, you know?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But then also when it's not
nice out, having a drink.
Isn't that good?
-Okay.
-You know, even it's like
the kind of thing, like,
when it's, like,
snowing out in New York,
you want a little red wine.
-Yeah!
-And then, when it's spring
and it's beautiful,
you want that red wine.
[ Laughter ]
You know?
-So is that...?
-Like, this is the kind of
drinking I've been doing lately.
-Okay.
-Okay, just to give you
sort of a frame of reference.
Like, I've been drinking
so much, like,
last night is the only night
I didn't drink, and I drank.
Do you know what I mean?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Okay, yeah.
-So, even you're, like,
your break day --
-My nights off are on.
-You have, like, a little.
-Yeah.
Like, have you ever been
so hungover,
you just have
to, like, leave town?
[ Laughter ]
You're just, like, you don't
even know where you're going.
You're just kind of shaking,
packing toiletries, you know?
[ Laughter ]
No?
-Do you know, is this,
like, a blackout situation?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Usually after a blackout.
I don't black any out any more,
I don't think.
-You don't? That's good. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-No, because, you know,
it used to be cool to black out.
It would be like,
"I blacked out,"
and everyone's like,
"you're the best," you know?
But really, nothing good
ever happens in a blackout.
Like, I've never woken up like,
"What is this pilates mat
doing out?"
You know?
"Oh, my God, I posted a
thoughtful James Baldwin quote?"
Like, that's not --
that's not really how it goes.
-We were both out very late.
It was very late for me
on Monday.
Met Ball.
-Whoa-oh, model!
-There you go, the Met ball.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is a beautiful photo.
You took a couple of
really nice groupies, as well.
-Oh, yeah.
-Group photos.
-Look at the Hadid sister,
right there.
Look at that.
[ Laughter ]
-And there she is, there.
I like how you showed,
"I can be with people
who also have sunglasses
and people who don't."
-And people
who don't have sunglasses.
I can still be with them,
as well.
-Yeah, very nice.
-Look at these hags.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's not a contest,
but it is, really.
-But I am winning.
-You're going to frame this and
call it "Amy and Three Hags."
-Well, that's what it is.
[ Laughter ]
-There were a lot of -
I mean, you know,
there were a lot of people who I
think are most famous
for their work on reality shows
at the Met.
Are you a fan
of reality shows yourself?
-Oh, my God, am I ever.
-Are you really?
-Of course, yeah.
I watch, like,
every reality show,
and it's hard,
but I find the time.
-That's really good.
-Have you been watching --
does anybody watch
"Selling Sunset"?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, okay.
It's a realty --
it's a realty reality show.
-Okay, gotcha.
-It's about realtors in L.A.
And these women, they dress
kind of like anime dinosaurs,
you know,
like very crazy outfits.
And they sell these
huge multimillion-dollar --
and I'm just laughing,
thinking about if they ever
tried to do that in New York,
like a "Selling Sunset,"
like "Selling Stuytown,"
you know,
just the apartments
for the same price
would just be like a railroad
with, like, a roommate,
you know?
And the realtors
wouldn't look like those.
They'd be, like,
just begrudging, you know,
"Uh, that's not officially
on the market," you know?
Just you could never have a show
like that here.
[ Laughter ]
-This is a nice milestone,
your son, Gene.
I've been lucky enough to cross
paths with Gene over the years.
-You guys see each other
at the gym, mm-hmm.
-Turning three.
-Turning three tomorrow!
-Tomorrow!
-My little baby!
[ Cheers and applause ]
My little baby guy! Yes.
-Gene, where did the name Gene
come from?
-Well, actually, Gene was
my husband's mom's name.
His mom's name was Jean,
and she died, which is sad.
-Mm-hmm.
-But to not have
a mother-in-law?
-Right.
[ Light laughter ]
-I'm sorry!
Was that a crowd-pleaser?
-How did you think it would go?
How did you think it would go?
-I thought people would be like,
"Oh, that's kind of funny,
she doesn't have
a mother-in-law."
I mean, but I guess
you're right.
I guess, you know --
I think we can all agree
it would be better
if she were alive.
-Yes, but --
-Except she's not.
[ Laughter ]
No, but, so,
we wanted to honor her.
We named our son Gene.
And then, as you know, my
husband's last name is Fischer,
so Gene Fisher.
Middle name,
named him for Dave Attell.
So, you know, a month in,
I realized that I'd named my son
"Genital" Fischer.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Took a full month.
-Gene Attell Fisher, yes.
-Yeah.
-So, yeah, take it in.
Take all the time you need.
-It is a hard thing.
-Let it wash over you
like it did me.
[ Laughter ]
-There basically living through,
in a moment,
what took you a full month.
-Right, a month. One month.
But it wasn't a vulnerable time
at all when you're a new mom.
-Right, you want to make sure
you're doing everything perfect
as a new mom.
And then, 30 days in,
it dawns on you.
-You just realize
you've already --
like, has anybody
ever messed up to that level?
Like, probably not.
-But you changed it.
-So we changed it, yeah.
And I hope it's better.
We changed his middle name
to Dingleberry Fist Crap.
Is that better, Dingleberry?
Is that good?
-Weirdly is better.
[ Laughter ]
And now this is about
the age introducing him
to Disney films,
I would imagine.
-You know, we've been trying,
but they're real problematic.
Like, I'm sure
you've seen, like,
they have all the warnings now.
-Yeah, there's, like, a title
card on almost everything.
-Just like, "We're sorry!
You know, we're going to still
show it to you," but, um --
So I tried showing --
I was really excited
to show him "Peter Pan,"
and we started
and then like,
you know, not too far in,
there's, like, an Indian man
in a headdress, like, "ohh!"
And I'm like, "Okay, no, this is
not good, this is not good."
[ Laughter ]
And then all the women,
it's, like, mostly just
those mermaids in "Peter Pan."
They're topless,
and they all speak in a whisper.
"Oh, Peter!
Oh, I'm so wet, I'm a mermaid."
[ Laughter ]
-Is that actual dialogue?
-It's actual dialogue.
Check it, check it.
I'm like, "I don't want my son
to see this," you know?
So we watched "Jungle Book."
Don't even try with that.
And then so I'm like,
"Let's scrub forward.
I'm sure the newer ones
are better."
And so we watched --
we wanted to watch "Tangled,"
which is about Rapunzel.
And a couple spoilers
are coming your way.
But in "Tangled,"
if she cuts her hair,
it turns brown!
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, and that happens
in the movie, okay?
And then she has
short brown hair,
and even though she's hideous,
the prince still
finds a way to love her.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that a beautiful message?
-He puts up with a girl
who has short brown hair?
-The deformity of brown hair,
yeah.
It's just --
It's tough, you know?
These movies -- and I love
the "Monsters, Inc." movies,
but there's, like, no women.
You know, it's like,
everybody's got to do better.
-It's always
so great to see you.
Thank you so much
for being here.
You guys, that's Amy Schumer.
"Life & Beth" is fantastic!
It's streaming now on Hulu.
We'll be right back
with Jennifer Grey.